>>> THE NATION IS ON FIRE.
THOSE WORDS FROM ONE NIGERIAN
SENATOR AS LAWMAKERS DEMAND THE
PRESIDENT DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY TO ADDRESS ARISING
VIOLENCE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE WANT TO BREAKDOWN THE
SECURITY CRISIS, EXPLAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WHERE.
FIRST, THE NORTHEAST.
THIS IS WHERE BOKO HARAM BEGAN.
THE ISLAMIC MILITANTS HAVE BEEN
TERRORIZING THE REGION AND
BEYOND FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
THEN THE NORTHWEST, PLAGUED BY
MASS KIDNAPPINGS FOR RANSOM,
MOSTLY BY CRIMINAL GANGS.
THE PROTESTS IN THE VIDEO ARE
DEMANDING THAT A SECURITY AFTER
SCHOOL BOYS WERE ABDUCTED.
THEY SAY NOWHERE IS SAFE AND
PEOPLE ARE FED UP.
>> WE ARE LIVING IN AGONY AND
TEARS.
LIVING IN A SITUATION WHEREBY WE
CAN'T MOVE FROM ONE PLACE UNTIL
YOU CAN'T TRAVEL WITHOUT FEAR.
>> ON TOP OF THAT IN CENTRAL
NIGERIA, THERE ARE LONG-STANDING
CLASHES BETWEEN HERDERS AND
FARMERS, IN THE SOUTH,
SEPARATIST MOVEMENT AND SOUTHERN
OIL RICH DELTA, PIRACY A MAJOR
CONCERN AS WELL.
THAT'S THE PART OF THE COUNTRY
THAT FUELS THE ECONOMY AND IT
REMAINS VERY, VERY IMPOVERISHED
WITH HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
CRITICS SAY THE PRESIDENT HASN'T
DONE ENOUGH TO ADDRESS THE
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY.
HE IS A FORMER COMMANDER THAT
PROMISED TO STABILIZE THE
COUNTRY AND YET THE SITUATION
CONTINUES TO WORSEN.
I WANT TO BRING IN EDITOR OF THE
AFRICA REPORT JOINING US LIVE
FROM PARIS.
ONE GOVERNOR IN NIGERIA ACTUALLY
SAID THAT THE SITUATION WHEN IT
COMES TO SECURITY OF NIGERIA IS
SO BAD, HE RECOMMENDED THAT
SCHOOLS IN NIGERIA SHOULD ONLY
OPERATE 30 MINUTES FROM A
MILITARY BASE.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY TO KEEP
SCHOOL CHILDREN SAFE IN HIS
STATE.
HOW MUCH IS MISTRUST AND THE
PERCEIVED WEAKNESS OF THE
COUNTRY'S SECURITY FORCES REALLY
DRIVING THE VIOLENCE DO YOU
THINK, NICHOLAS?
>> WELL, IT WAS A REAL ADMISSION
OF FAILURE, FOR SOMEONE SO HIGH
UP IN THE RULING PARTY TO SAY
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE LOOKING TO
SITE THEIR ESTABLISHMENTS A HALF
HOUR FROM MILITARY
ESTABLISHMENTS, MILITARY BASES,
AND NOT EVEN -- SAYING POLICE
STATIONS WEREN'T GOOD ENOUGH,
HAVE TO BE 30 MINUTES AWAY FROM
THE ARMY.
IT SHOWS THAT THE LEVEL OF
THREAT HAS GOT TO A PLACE WHERE
THE AVERAGE POLICE FORCE SIMPLY
ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
THERE'S HUGE ANGER AS YOUR
REPORT CAPTURED ABOUT THE STATE
OF INSECURITY IN NIGERIA.
IT IS NOT NEW BUT IT HAS BEEN
GETTING STEADILY WORSE OVER THE
LAST DECADE.
LAST YEAR WE SAW BIG PUBLIC
PROTESTS ABOUT POLICE BRUTALITY
IN NIGERIA, THE PROTESTS,
BECAUSE THERE'S A FEELING THE
POLICE FORCE IN NIGERIA JUST
ISN'T DOING ITS JOB AND WORSE
THAN THAT, THEY'RE OFTEN NO
BETTER THAN CRIMINALS THEMSELVES
IF YOU LISTEN TO CERTAIN
ACTIVISTS.
>> AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CHAD.
BOKO HARAM AS YOU AND I BOTH
KNOW, OPERATES LARGELY IN
NIGERIA, BUT ALSO SPREAD ACROSS
WESTERN CHAD.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT COUNTRY LOST ITS LONG TIME
STRONG MAN LEADER, I AND THE
INSTABILITY AS A RESULT OF THAT,
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR STRONGER
BOKO HARAM IN NIGERIA DO YOU
THINK?
>> WE HAVE SPOKEN TO ELEMENTS OF
THE SECURITY FORCES IN NIGERIA
WHO CLAIM THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
PICK UP SOME OF THE SLACK THAT
WILL CERTAINLY BE APPEARING NOW
THAT PRESIDENT DEBY IS OUT OF
THE PICTURE.
JUST FOR CONTEXT, CHAD DID MOST
OF THE HEAVY LIFTING FOR
SECURITY IN THE SAHEL IN RATHER
BRUTAL FASHION BUT IT WAS
POLICING PARTS OF MALI, NIGER.
NOW THAT IT IS FACING ITS OWN
INTERNAL SECURITY CRISIS, FRANCE
HAS INDICATED IT IS NOT HAPPY
WITH THE MOVE, CHAD WILL BE
CONSUMED WITH ITS OWN INTERNAL
POLITICS.
WHAT WILL THAT MEAN FOR BOKO
HARAM?
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO OPERATE
MORE EASILY ON BOARDERS OF
NIGERIA?
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE RISK, EVEN
IF THE NIGERIAN ARMY SAYS IT IS
UP TO THE JOB.
WE SAW A FEW DAYS AGO LAST WEEK
BOKO HARAM WAVING THE BLACK FLAG
IN NIGER STATE.
THAT'S JUST TWO HOURS DRIVE FROM
THE CAPITAL ABUJA.
CLEARLY THE NIGERIAN ARMY HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO PREVENT IT
MAKING THOSE KINDS OF IN ROADS.
>> I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO
OUR VIEWERS THAT NATURALLY WHEN
A COUNTRY EXPERIENCES THIS LEVEL
OF VIOLENCE, THERE'S CLEARLY
GOING TO BE REASONS BEHIND IT.
ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES THAT
UNDERPINS NIGERIA'S VIOLENCE,
RISING VIOLENCE, POOR SECURITY
EXACE
IS THE ECONOMY.
PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY, SUFFERING
FROM UNEMPLOYMENT, POVERTY.
THAT'S DRIVING BANDITS AND YOU
HAVE CLIMATE CHANGE, DRIVING
SOME VIOLENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
HERDSMEN AND FARMERS AS WELL.
HOW MUCH IS THE ECONOMY A FACTOR
DO YOU THINK?
>> CERTAINLY IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
STRUCTURAL ISSUES.
YOU MENTION THE NORTH AND THE
HERDERS, THE SAHEL IS TRYING.
WHERE PEOPLE USED TO GRAZE
CATTLE IS TURNING TO DUST IN THE
NORTH, THEY'RE BEING PUSHED
FURTHER SOUTH, AND THAT'S
COLLIDING WITH FARMERS WHO HAVE
BEEN SETTLED THERE FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS, AND WHO SUDDENLY
HAVE INCURSIONS OF HERDSMEN,
ALLOW CATTLE TO GRAZE ON THEIR
CROPS.
THAT'S BEEN AN INCREDIBLE DRIVER
OF VIOLENCE.
CLEARLY THERE'S AN ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUSE.
THEN IN THE WIDER ECONOMY THIS
IS NOT AN ECONOMY PRODUCING JOBS
AT THE RATE IT SHOULD AND THERE
ARE OBVIOUS BLOCKING POINTS,
THERE'S NO POWER, THE ROAD
SYSTEM IS NOT WHAT IT SHOULD BE,
AND PORTS ARE REALLY RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S A CLEAR POTENTIAL.
HOWEVER, SUCCESSFUL GOVERNMENTS
IN NIGERIA HAVE NOT REALLY BEEN
ABLE TO GET THEIR HANDS AROUND
THE PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AFRICAN DEVELOPMENT BANK HAS
POINTED TO AGRICULTURE IN THE
NORTH BEING ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE MILLIONS OF JOBS
TO BE CREATED.
UNTIL THEY GET IRRIGATION AND
POWER SORTED OUT, THAT'S N